welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with author
jim quick celebrity brain trainer
author of limitless founder of quick
learning
kwik that's a pretty handy last name huh
we covered speed reading and
comprehension and i've actually used his
technique
and it has improved my speed reading
by 10 to 25 depending on what i'm
reading and my level of comprehension
is better i don't know if my brain's
working any faster but i need might need
more time with that he also has a
podcast
called quick brain podcast that's worth
checking out
he had a major learning disability or
learning disabilities as a kid that he
overcame
due to a rather serious head injury
so that was very interesting to cover he
believes people are
capable of extraordinary things if
they're given the tools
to learn properly so hopefully this
podcast will help with that and
i think i might i might try to get him
back on in the future because i really
wanted to get into memory and we didn't
get into that as much as i wanted to
but we definitely got into a lot uh this
episode is brought to you by
murtycreative.co who makes my favorite
leather journals
uh they make binders journals pens
wallets coasters
name tags glasses holders cup holders
i'm waiting on the wallet actually i
want to try that out
but i use their journal now it's really
nice thick leather
engravable if you use the code mp at
mertycreative.co
they'll give you free engravings and
they'll know you came from here
but i've been using it because it's a
new year to visualize
my future if you don't write down your
goals
or think about them manifest them
as the hippies say uh how are you going
to achieve them
and i find handwriting is a much nicer
way of doing these things it kind of
sinks into my soul better
so i use their journal
m-u-r-d-y-creative.co codemp
they also have a podcast mardi
creative.co
you can google that on youtube you can't
google anything on youtube i guess or
youtube is google anyway
i'm getting away from myself you can
look up
murdy creative.co on youtube and get
their podcast
which is full of neat details about how
to start your own small business
so thank you to them for the podcast
sponsorship
and i hope you enjoy this episode i
really enjoyed this episode
also it was my birthday a couple days
ago and now i'm 29
what up almost 30.
[Music]
so
[Music]
jim quick thank you so much for joining
me
hello thank you for having me on your
show and thank you everyone who's
joining us for this brainy
conversation we're about to have yeah
i'm stoked i have your book here
and speed reading specifically is
something i've
really been interested in because i
consume a lot of books and if i could
consume them faster
that would be ideal and i haven't
managed to
speed up my i think this rate of
comprehension
very much so i have a whole bunch of
questions to throw at you and
hopefully by the end i'll have a better
idea of how to
increase my comprehension rate um
so let's get started first off i guess
can you give my audience a bit of a
background if they don't know who you
are
um about who you are and what it is that
you do yeah
um i mean a lot of people call me a
brain coach
for the past 29 years i've had the
opportunity to work with people of all
ages and stages from
children with learning challenges to
aging seniors
to high performers you know everyone in
between helping them to upgrade the most
important technology
which is the human brain and i show them
very practical things that they could do
to have better focus to improve their
memory to help uh well you know overcome
like the the distractions or the monkey
minds
to be able to handle information
overload and then overwhelm
by upgrading these skills that
unfortunately aren't readily taught in
school
when people see me on stages i live
stages or even on social media i'll do
these demonstrations where i'll
you know memorize 50 or 100 people's
names in an audience or do these kind of
mental feeds but i always tell people
i don't do this to impress you i really
do just express to you what's possible
because the truth is everyone listening
to this could do that and a lot more
it's just we weren't taught if anything
i feel like the school system sometimes
taught us a lie that somehow our memory
or
potential or learning somehow fixed like
our shoe size
you know so i think this conversation
might work is really about transcending
it's about ending the trans sending this
mass hypnosis
sometimes through marketing or media
other people's expectations that somehow
we're not smart enough or
are focused enough or be able to have it
be able to have this potential
and the reason why i know it is because
i grew up with some pretty severe
learning challenges
when i was five years old i had a
traumatic brain injury very uh
in kindergarten class and from there i
was rushed to the emergency room my
parents said i
just was not the same where before i was
very curious very playful
energized i became extremely shut down
the debilitating i mean i couldn't learn
i couldn't focus
i couldn't remember what happened if you
don't mind me asking
i was in kindergarten class and there
were these this noise the sirens outside
uh and we couldn't see what was going on
outside because we were so tiny right
which is great i'm just five years old
kindergarten and so we all grabbed our
chairs from our desk and put it by the
the windowsills
and we stood up and there were the old
fire trucks outside
and um while i was looking at and i had
this
reverence for yeah i talk about
superheroes a lot and
because i feel like i taught myself how
to read by reading comic books and
something about superheroes just yeah me
too yeah and uh but my environment
the environment and women they were like
these modern day superheroes they had
their costumes and they had their you
know utility belts and running to save
the day
anyway when i was mesmerizing looking at
these fire trucks um
another kid pulled my chair
out from underneath me to use it to look
you know not maliciously but
i went headfirst into an iron-grade
radiator
oh and blood everything i was rushed to
the hospital
and but the big effect you know i became
very shut down
very introverted and shy i had
learning difficulties it took me three
years longer just learned how to
read basic reading than all of everyone
else in class
when i was nine a teacher i was slowing
down the class and i was being teased
for it
and a teacher i think well-intentioned
she was coming to my defense
but she pointed to me in front of the
whole class and said that's the boy with
the broken brain
and kind of like leave him alone but
yeah well well-intentioned
yeah all i remembered was like oh my god
i have a broken brain
and adults have to be very careful of
their external words because
they sometimes become a child's internal
words so every single time
i um i didn't do well on a quiz or test
which was often
every time i wasn't picked for sports
which was like all the time i would say
oh because i have a broken brain
and that self-talk became my that label
became my limit
and so that was pretty much you know my
schooling all through
until i graduated high school i just
struggled
uh became again painfully shy like i
would my parents got called in one time
because i was being i was
failing high school english and uh
gave me this extra credit report to do
on you know
einstein and anyway i put
like all my effort into it for two
months so we'd go right after school
the library and put it typed out and you
know and i
had it professionally bound and
everything i was ready to turn and then
the day was due
and uh it really represented my
potential but
at the class that day the teacher said
we have a surprise for everyone
jim comes in from the class to give you
a book report and i was like
what like i didn't i've never done
public speaking i always
my superpower was shrinking down like
becoming invisible because i didn't want
to be called on i was
behind the tall kids all the way in the
back you know what i mean and i was
phobic of public speaking
um you know my heart was beating out
each other i couldn't breathe and i lied
i looked right at her and i said
i didn't do it and you see them just
space
but as the class left i remember
being you know 13 14 years old going
into my backpack
on the way out taking out my this like
you know well-bound
thing that i put my whole energy effort
and i just threw it out in the trash
you know that's how terrified it was um
i felt like i was
like throwing out my dreams my hopes and
so that was my challenges
and so you know when i was 18 i
discovered uh
you know there's more understanding
adult learning theory and just fun with
the whole
you know confluence of events that i
just i realized that
it's not how smart you are it's not how
smart your kids are it's not how smart
you are it's how are you smart
and i discovered new ways of learning
because i always thought it was
interesting in school they teach you
what to learn
what to focus on what to remember what
to read what's a thing but not how to do
any of those things
there are no classes on how to learn how
to focus and content
how to remember things how to read
better and understand
more how to critically think you know
and be able to solve problems and so i
devoted my life the past 29 years since
helping people to have these strategies
to be able to fill in those gaps in our
education system
so because i believe in knowledge is
power learning is our superpower and is
the most important skill
to have in the 21st century because you
can learn how to focus
memorize read better critically think
solve problems
retain information then you can apply
towards what anything
you can apply towards your diet money
management martial arts music
easier so that that's my mission is no
brain left behind
build better brighter brains cool
well that's quite a that's quite an
intro i don't think i was expecting that
i'm glad you started off though
with your background with a traumatic
brain injury because
i asked i i always ask my instagram if
they have questions for the guest
just to kind of see what the main i
guess
main question is for the guests and a
lot of those people say i have a
learning disability
i have a traumatic brain injury there
are a lot of people like that and
is this going to work for me um but
before we get into that
how how do you know that you
aren't just really smart like
how do you know that this this is
separate from something like iq
yeah um so let's let's unpack that um
i'm not i'm not a big subscriber to iq
um i could show anyone how to do better
on iq test
you know this this idea that you take a
test when you're a child and that's your
kind of your your number when you're
from your 8 to 88
and it's fixed i i definitely have more
of a growth mindset
the other challenge is that i don't
think it's fixed i think it's malleable
and the other thing is i also feel like
it doesn't test necessarily
all the areas of intelligence because
what is really genius
you know and so even when you look at
standardized tests
back in school here in the states we
have like sats and everything it's like
verbal and mathematical and while those
are two very important areas of
intelligence
you know it's not testing you know
emotional intelligence not testing
interpersonal intelligence
visual spatial intelligence kinesthetic
music intelligence you know these other
areas i also don't think it's as
complete
but the reason why i know it's possible
is because i didn't grow up with any of
these kind of yeah i didn't have any of
these kind of abilities beforehand
it's been my experience to the two
things me as a personal testimony that i
didn't have i was
i was i remember in elementary school so
i used to hang out with all the geeky
kids
because um not because i had the only
thing we did i didn't have their grades
but i had the same interest like
dungeons and dragons and video games and
comic books right
but i remember when uh the teacher came
in one day and took all my friends
and they're like hey we're creating a
group for you and it's called uh mask
mask and it was 10 for more able student
program
these are the more able students yeah
that
definitely doesn't lead to bullying yeah
exactly and i
was uh well on the other side of it
though i wasn't included in that group
so i grabbed another classmate because
he also wasn't included and we created a
group called lasp
less able student program and that
that's where my mentality was back in
elementary school so that that's
that's funny though yeah i mean i was on
the other side of the bell curve that
made the other ones like possible so i
know from personal like
i believe and also 29 years we have
students online
195 nations right we have a education
podcast one of the top ones in the world
we have a i've been doing this for 29
years field tested with every
so many people in front 250 000 people a
year
so i field tested this so i know what
works what does it works and i've found
that the people that it's no there's no
such thing as a good or bad memory
or a good a bad brain there's a trained
brain a trained memory and an untrained
memory
and so my my mission is to really show
people
even your fans your followers if they
have traumatic brain injuries i've had
three
you know if they have had you know
stroke eight you know that
age background like you certainly i all
play a factor
you know and i train a lot of a lot of
hospitals uh
the cleveland clinic the center for
brain health there and we find that one
third of your
the potential is preterm by genetics and
biology roughly
um two-thirds is in your influence and
control so in your lifestyle things that
you know your past guests have talked
about you know
andrew and max they you know the food
you're eating your sleep and the other
things that can actually move the needle
and so we have more we have more
influence than we think
cool okay i like that that's a very much
more positive outlook anyway
you have a control over two-thirds of
your potential kind of
and you always want to control the
controllables right you want to get yeah
people say it's more with epigenetics
and you know and like so but it's just
you want to control what you can control
and so my my goal is to give people
more limitless it's not about being
perfect it's about advancing progressing
beyond what you believe is possible but
it starts with personal responsibility
right taking responsibility for for
where you are that your past might have
shaped
you and your expectation or anything but
we have we have control here
yeah i had a very interesting experience
when i was
ill so i had an autoimmune disorder i
was on a whole bunch of medication
and my memory was terrible and i
i now know that was because i was like
inflamed and on a whole bunch of drugs
but i couldn't repeat a phone number if
someone told me their phone number i
couldn't repeat it back to them
and i've spoken to other people who are
also on medication and a lot of people
on meds have that problem they can't
remember a seven digit number
and as soon as i got healthier
completely dramatically trained
changed my diet and got off of all the
medication and waited a little bit
it was like my memory completely
switched seven digit numbers were easy
i started remembering lyrics to songs
i'd heard years ago
that i didn't realize were stored uh so
there's a lot
and that was a reality i'd never
experienced so there's a lot you have
control over that people don't
realize so i love this conversation
because it's just showing people what's
possible i believe that the life
that you live are the lessons you teach
you know and then showing people that
you go
from that you know below like for me i
went below normal to normal
to to above but it came through
discipline and came through our choices
you know came through our lifestyle
there there's always something that we
could do to make things better
okay so how did you start did you start
with mindset like what
changed so when i was um
18 i was fortunate to get into a local
university
state school and um i purposely chose a
school where
where i didn't know anyone was going to
it because i knew their expectations of
my identity
when you're growing up with me would
shape like my potential
and i took all these classes and because
i wanted to
show the world show myself that i could
do this get a fresh start i thought
freshman men fresh start i don't know
and um and i actually did worse and um
and my my family didn't have the money
for you know they immigrated to
united states we didn't you know my mom
lived in the background laundry mat that
that whole
speak the language and my parents my
father's parents died at the age of 13
had to move here to live with his aunt
like this whole story
but like we didn't have the resources to
be there so i was ready to quit
because i you know i just thought i
wasn't smart enough why waste the money
um and my friend of mine said hey
that's a big decision michael gets in
perspective and i think perspective is
very important to have a different point
of view
and for me perspective changes when you
change your place or the people you're
with
right and i go home visit his
family that weekend and different
kind of lifestyle you know pretty well
off nice beautiful home
on the water and the father walks me
around this property asked me a very
interesting question
but as an insecure 18 year old the worst
question you could ask me
he says how school and i just break down
and i'm pretty like concerned i it's
really hard to start falling in front of
this complete stranger and i tell him a
whole story a broken brain learning
challenges
ready to quit school he says why are you
in school
what do you want to be do have [ __ ] and
i honestly didn't have an answer
no one's ever asked me that question i
just thought you just have to do this
right
and when i go to answer him he's a stop
and he takes out a piece of paper and
his pocket and he
in like a notebook and he tears off a
couple sheets give me a pen
and he says write it down and writing
down things i find that it's
it's it's a nice first step to take
something invisible and make it visible
and after i don't know how much time
goes by but i have like a bucket list
right and i start folding it to put in
my pocket and he rips it out of my hand
and he starts to read it to himself and
i'm freaking out because you know i'm
afraid of being judged i'm very insecure
and
he looks up to me he looks at me he says
you're this close to everything on this
list
and for people not watching this on the
video it's about spreading my index
fingers like a foot apart
and he takes that's like no way give me
10 lifetimes i'm not going to crack that
list
and he takes his fingers and he puts
them in the side of my head meaning what
was on the ins
in between you know my brain was like
the key or bridge
and he takes me to his home long story
short i'm in a room full of books
and remember i it's like being in room
full of snakes like i'm like i don't
i've never read a book cover to cover my
teachers wouldn't be surprised if i read
a book much less wrote a book
but what makes it worse he starts going
to shelves and grabbing snakes and
handing them to me
and i'm looking at the titles and
they're these biographies of men and
women in history
it's very early personal growth books
and he says jim you need to read one of
these books
a week and i was like fighting for my
limitations and i was like i can't do it
i have so much score
he says jim don't let school be in the
way of education it was a mark 20 quote
right like but i didn't realize at the
time
and and i was like he still can't do it
if i promise that i'm going to do it i
can't do it
and smart moon he reaches into his
pocket takes out my bucket list
and he starts reading out loud all my
dreams and i don't know
michelle like it's like like hearing
your dreams
and goals in another person's voice and
chanted out in the universe it messed
with my mind
my my soul is pretty you know fierce and
honestly a lot of things on that list
were things i wanted to do for my
parents
that they could never afford to do for
themselves would never do so i agree to
read it
i go back to school and then those books
end up changing send me on a different
direction and change my life
and why i'm here with you today is my
when i learned the potential of the mind
and i started studying multiple
intelligence their adult learning theory
ancient mnemonics speed reading all this
stuff 60 days into it light switch
flipped on i started just to breeze
through school
but i got angry because i was like maybe
you felt the same way when you got sick
like why weren't you taught like certain
basic things yeah
die and everything i got really upset
because every day
of my childhood and i started so i
started to teach other people
like friends and then one of my very
first students she was a freshman in
college
i swear to you she read 30 books in 30
days talk about speed reading
not get the gist of it scandal read it
and i wanted to know
not how i taught her how i want to know
why
because most people don't do that i
found out her mother was dying of cancer
terminal two months to live doctor said
in the book she was reading were books
to save her mom's life you know and
people who have never had to like help
they don't read it's hard to relate to
right but it's like we don't have your
health like i've had a number of
health issues you know in my lifetime
when you don't like someone who has
their health has a thousand dreams
someone who doesn't have their health
they have like one dream yeah yeah
that's like the one thing
and i i wish your luck and everything
else like that because the book she was
bringing were focused on health and
wellness
diet and six months later i had to talk
to his own
lady she's crying hysterically and when
she stops i find out they're tears of
joy
and her mother not only survived but her
god's getting better doctors don't know
how why they called a miracle
literally they said it's a miracle but
her mother treated 100 the great advice
she got from her daughter who learned it
from all these books
and in that moment it changed my life
because i realized that knowledge is
power
learning is our superpower and it's a
superpower we all have
we just weren't taught how to unleash it
and that's you know in schools and
everything that's why i dedicated my
life
29 years ago and i've been doing it
every day since yeah okay i
i completely agree there was uh for me i
had
a mind change right i realized that the
health care system wasn't going to help
because it had been let's see age 7 to
23.
they'd tried everything and i was still
getting sicker and sicker and sicker
uh and so i thought okay this actually
isn't working
i'm just going to study until i find the
answer
and it turns out this is something that
shocked me because i thought okay it's
maybe it'll take me till i'm 60 because
this is an incurable problem
and maybe i'll never be able to figure
it out but it took me
two three years before i put my
autoimmune disorder into remission
but that was you know 14 hours a day of
just reading everything i could possibly
read
and it turns out i've had to deal with
other people's health problems and
other issues it turns out i do believe
this
that if you are motivated enough and
somebody's health or your own health is
the number one
motivator or some life and death
situation if you're motivated enough
you can just we have access to so much
information
the internet is an insane place right
you can be connected to almost anybody
in the entire world
so you can just research until you
figure out the answer
as long as you're out of the mindset
that there isn't an answer which
everyone around you generally tells you
yeah i agree i think we it's a parallel
journey today where your autoimmune
you know the whole situation was with my
learning difficulties
and i was just like struggling every day
and then you know not
not looking to the experts you know get
quote unquote traditional experts but
also
taking responsibility and knowing that
you're right you have unfettered access
to all the individuals and ideas of the
world
you know and taking the personal
responsibility and as opposed to being
on the effect
you know being a thermometer versus a
thermostat thermometer just reacts and
is you know
everything but as a put supposed to be a
thermostat where you set an
intention you set a goal at temperature
and then you know
you make the external react to you yeah
okay so so how did you how did you start
you said you had this you started by
reading
i started reading these books and that
opened up a new direction i think
one step in another direction completely
changes your destination
you know and that's why i think reading
is you know reading is so important and
this is something i never i couldn't
appreciate because i was never a great
reader
so i didn't do it very often because
when you're not good at something
it's not something you feel comfortable
doing and
i was you know i i didn't know it and i
think part of life
right now is it's not only a divide of
those who have and don't have
it's also those who know and those who
just don't know
right and so you know and now ignorance
is a choice when you have
access to everything right that's a
choice you know in
in limitless i have a quote from a
french philosopher and he says
life is the c between b and d life is c
between b and d b stands for birth d
stands for death
c life it's our choices choices that
even right now these difficult times
can diminish you these difficult times
can destroy you or these difficult times
can develop you
ultimately we decide so i'm i'm i admire
and respect and in awe of individuals
like yourself that step up that have the
persistence to show up every single day
and not give up
even when everything else you know would
give you evidence and you can make all
the excuses and complaining about it
but you still people still persevere and
you know that's the lesson that i've
learned this year is that
you know we have an incredible amount of
resilience and grit
when we're put under pressure that
through challenge can come
change and we hear a lot about
post-traumatic stress
we don't hear a lot about post-traumatic
growth though people have gone through
adversity and they've you've come
out of it okay and you find meaning you
found
strength you find clarity you find
mission right
you know and that's you know that's
that's the brighter side of this
that your struggles can lead to your
think about it my my two biggest
challenges
were so debilitating i had the severe
learning challenges and public speaking
challenges
what do i do for a living like i just
public speak on learning
right so the universe has a sense of
humor but um
but that's for sure yeah so we all we
could come out of this stronger smarter
better and
that's my hopes for everybody yeah
one of the things i've been really
interested in figuring out is why
when you put you can put two people in a
really horrible situation
like a life-and-death situation and you
can have one person come
out a better person um not a better but
stronger stay stronger you can have one
person end up
with goals and a plan and having
conquered something and you can have the
other person just
flattened and by the same situation
which is and a reasonable expectation
for that situation would be to flatten
somebody
but sometimes that doesn't happen to
people which is really encouraging
yeah it's it's interesting when people
could be put under similar pressure
you know and they come out of it
different and part of it is
just one of my favorite books you know i
i obviously read
a lot now but one of those in their
books like man search for meaning
that we always can make a decision on
what things what to focus on
and also what do those things mean you
know and so for me
i chose to focus on it's i talk about
this thing in the book called
you know this dominant question that we
have anywhere from 50 to 70
000 thoughts a day and a lot of those
thoughts come in the form of questions
that we're asking ourselves and i think
thinking is this process of asking and
answering questions of ourselves
and some people listening might be
thinking is that true but notice you had
to ask a question and think about it
right
but i talk about how there are certain
dominant questions that we ask
and those questions director focus it
kind of hijacks as part of our brain
the reticular activating system
determine what's important to us because
at any given time
there's a billion stimuli we could be
focusing on right
focus on all that consciously we would
go insane so when you ask those
questions it shows your reality like for
example
years ago my sister you know was send me
these postcards and these emails of like
a very specific breed of dog it was a
pug dog and i was like why my question
was why she keeps sending these
photos and uh you know people aren't
familiar with the breed just like little
smushing faces we could dress them up
like ballerinas
they don't care and um and what's funny
thing happened though is i just started
seeing these pug dogs everywhere though
yeah oh at the health food store i'd be
at the encounter i'd be holding
somebody in front of me holding a pug
dog you know and i was like what and i'd
be running in my neighborhood
and somebody i swear to you was this guy
was walking six pug dogs
and my question for everyone listening
and this is kind of an obvious answer
but
humor me where did these magically just
appear where were these pub dogs before
they didn't just magically appear they
were always there but they
primarily our brain is a deletion device
right we're trying to keep information
out otherwise you know we would go crazy
and so i never paid attention because it
wasn't important but once i started the
question
it became important i started seeing it
and my my hypothesis for people who are
listening they're not asking about
questions to direct their focus even
when you read something
have you ever read something get to the
end and just forget what you just read
and you go back and maybe reread it yeah
you know and then you still know what
you just read or you get someone's name
and you forget it
part of it is if you just directed the
questions and you have questions
for what you're reading then you'll see
like oh there's a pub dog there's a pug
dog there's a pub dog because the
answers are always there
or if you have a question about you know
why do i want to remember this person's
name and show the person respect or or
to make a new friend or maybe practice
these things i learned on this podcast
then all of a sudden you have reasons
and those reasons will give you results
but we're not controlling those
questions
because a lot of those questions are
habitual right and so going back
to the you know the power of learning
when i was a kid
i was always like you know why am i
broken right now that's not very
empowering question
but then my questions became how do i
fix this right because if i'm broken the
opposite is fixing and then my obsessive
question was like
how do i fix all this stuff and then i
started the answer answer
answer yeah okay that's very interesting
i found that so i was miserably
depressed
so everything i saw was a negative right
why i can't do things and why things
won't work out
and they never where things never worked
out
it was almost a running joke in my
family about how everything would go
wrong
for me um and then when things
when i guess when i got my focus on
exactly
what i wanted to accomplish which was i
want to figure out my health problems
answers did start showing up and it was
it's very difficult for me to believe
that they were there and i just started
seeing them because it was
so different than my previous experience
like it felt it was such a
transformation that it felt like
they hadn't been there but because i
wanted them to be then they were showing
up which i know
logically doesn't really make any sense
but it was
it's crazy what happens when you focus
on something it is i i mean i have these
kind of
these quick isms where i just you know i
feel like it's because it helps people
to kind of build these groups and
people's brains they come
and become like these these splinters in
people's minds but i believe that
questions really are the answer to a lot
of it that if we direct those questions
and we don't make it just habitual like
if i ask questions like
why can't i ever do this then all i
guess i don't get all these answers why
am i never enough i'm gonna get these
answers which is not very empowering
right but if i ask myself questions like
like one of the myths i talk about in
the book is that knowledge alone is
power
it certainly is not a lot of people know
a lot of stuff but they don't have a
life that reflects that knowing right
so knowledge is potential power it comes
power when we utilize it
but you could direct your questions to
really turn that knowledge
into action by asking yourself questions
like how can i use this
like i'm obsessed when i listen to a
podcast or i read a book saying how can
i use this
because then i think answers answers
answers as opposed to somebody who
doesn't have that question
then i ask myself questions like why
must i use this because a lot of people
know how they could use it but they
don't use it
so i go to like like the feelings like
all the benefits that will come if i do
use this or i do try this breathing
experiment or something else
so i said why do i use it why must i use
this and i ask the third question
which is when will i use this right so
how can
i use this i think about all the
possibilities you know and then why must
i use it all the benefits so i feel like
doing something
and i say put in calendar like when will
i apply this
when will i try this experiment or this
diet or the shop or whatever
because i think one of the most powerful
productivity performance tools we have
is in our phones like our calendars
yeah we'll schedule a lot of things from
work or investors
mean whatever it is but we don't
schedule a lot of time their own growth
or the things that we want to commit to
and you know i feel like if you don't
schedule it it's just not going to
happen and then the day goes by
you could hijack the family and kids and
then you don't i didn't i didn't
meditate today i didn't do my cold
therapy today or i didn't
you know food prep whatever right yeah
yeah one of the one of the things i got
taught since i was a child which i think
i was pretty lucky
was to schedule everything and it was
almost to an obsessive degree
but so we may have gone a little bit
overboard but i did end up scheduling
especially when i was trying to figure
out my health problems scheduling
like every bit of my day in like 15 to
an hour intervals or it was like
wake up shower eat you know write and
that
really first it helps you feel like
you've accomplished things
because every time you do something on
your list to check whether or not it's
you know have a shower have a cold
shower or whatever
but uh that is a good trick it's very
goal-oriented behavior right it is and i
i could respect that because you know
there's
a lot of people it's not even just about
time management it's about priority
management
right i always tell people the most
important thing is to keep the most
important thing
the most important thing right the most
important thing is to keep the most
important things like the most important
thing
and for me and when you have a finite or
a limited amount of energy or
temperament because
of uh you know a physical condition then
you have to be more more relentless with
how you can invest your time your
attention and everything
you know like another dominant question
i have is what's the gift in this
otherwise i would be very i would get
very sour and very jaded very quick
with high learning challenges like
something i mentioned in the book and
it's just it's light but it's you know
it goes deep because i
had very very severe sleep issues you
know for most of my adult life
i found out i was sleeping for five
years
i was sleeping 90 to 90 minutes to two
hours
total a night you know that's and that's
just really bad and i found out and it
was it made it even worse
part of it was a big part of it was i
have i found out
that i was diagnosed um in ucla i had
severe sleep happening
severe i stopped breathing over 200 you
know 10 times a night
and each time was an episode for at
least 10 seconds i'm actually counting
to 10
and then so i would wake up not be able
to breathe right and i found out later
after that that my parents have apnea my
brothers
my siblings have app and sleep apnea and
so i would wake up and i would try
cpap and dental device and all these
things and nothing was really working
right i had this
very intensive surgery where they cut
out my uvula my soft palate
my tonsils and i got to make more you
know as an adult it's very painful
and it was exasperated because back in
school i wasn't a good learner so i pull
all nighters all the time so even at a
young age i would develop that habit of
not sleeping
because i had to work three times harder
to do
less right and then in my career i would
be
on three continents in one week right so
the jet lag and sleeping in foreign
environments and hotels you don't want
to be a memory expert
wake up and not remember what city
you're in right so all of that created
this situation where for years i just
and this being misdiagnosed and
everything else
i couldn't make this shift and my point
of bringing all this up is like i was
doing all this and i would be on stage
doing all these
mental performances and everything
because and we don't know what people
what battles people are facing
right they'd be fighting for their lives
every single day and not you know
right and that's why kindness is so
important you know now especially more
than ever
and but my point of bringing this up is
i asked myself this question that they
asked when i had these learning
challenges everything else where's the
gift
you know what then and then if that
there's no answer i was like well if
there was a gift what would the gift
come because i have to have a
perspective and a mindset
you know otherwise i'd be debilitated
right now i'm wanting to move forward
because there's no hope and i said
you know well part of it is number one
it forced me to double down on
everything i teach like i am world class
at what i do
because it's not it's because i had to
do it right i had to be
i had to learn how to read this much
faster this memory because otherwise
i'd be not be able to perform on this
deficit of sleep
right and then not only did i get that
benefit but the other gift i got
much like yours is i got so militant on
my time
right because when you have a finite
amount of energy or inducial or whatever
that's it you can't be doing everything
so it forced me to have this filtering
system where everything is a hell yes or
it's a hell no
like right now there's nowhere else i'd
rather be you know i don't know i should
be talking to
right now i'm fully here because i've
trained myself because wherever i am
i want to be there right and that
because i think a lot of people have
mental fatigue
or because they have too many windows
open right they say yeah
part of self-love is is realizing when
you say yes to someone
or something you're not saying no to
yourself part of self-love and self-care
is putting constraints and borders
around the things that you treasure
your time your emotions your heart you
know your family the things that you
treasure
and so those are two gifts that came out
of it you know and then i'm still asking
the question how can i make this better
how can i improve this and stuff and i
eventually found answers started
interviewing people on sleep
you know in our podcast and everything
else and then you know things change
hmm so that's a lot about prioritizing
what you want to do with your life
getting rid of all the
well waste of time see like not
everybody has the same energy education
the same network the same income same
whatever
but we all have 24 hours in a day right
86 400 seconds
and but it's for me it's really about
just like what you did you blocked off
this time this time this time
and it forced you to be really you know
very very serious about it
so you can kind of and not because so
many people are relaxed with their time
and
people like the reason why i give so
yeah like on our lives and i'm talking
is because
it feels time to listen to this right
now their time attention one thing they
can't get back they could always make
more money they could always do but they
can't get their time back
you know and me when i was searching for
answers it wasn't because i was lazy i
wasn't late
lazy at all i would work really hard but
i just didn't have access
in my mind to the right information
because i was going through
you know traditional like you would
traditional medicine i was going through
traditional education
and insanity is doing the same thing
over and over again expecting different
results so it takes
time there's a great book called the
structure of scientific revolution
that talks about it usually takes
somebody outside an industry that all in
the most innovation in in fashion and
technology and automotive comes from
somebody outside the industry like
elon musk looking saying because they're
not they don't they're not
taught the same they're not trapped
right the same learned helplessness
saying what if you did it this way like
if i was to build a cart
with today's technology yeah how would i
go about doing it you know it's kind of
like peter thiel's book
zero to one where you know he talks
about most people it's not innovation
it's incremental going from one to two
two to three three to four
but go from zero to one you're creating
something brand new
that wasn't there before and his dominic
one of his dominant questions talking
about power questions was
what if i had to reach my 10-year goal
but i only had six months to do it
right it forces you to ask a new
question this question forced you to do
i like that but that's the power of our
mind and so controlling the questions
that we ask
and whether we're reading or inputting
in this discovery
ask a new question you'll get an answer
ask a question no one's ever asked
before you'll get an answer no one's
ever gotten before
yeah okay let's switch just for a second
because i want to get back to this but
just for a second to something more
practical
so speed reading uh when when you do it
are you reading a sentence form like
across the page
or are you reading in chunks this is a
great question
if anyone's ever taken a traditional
speed reading class most traditional
speed reading
is more skimming scanning skipping yeah
and getting the gist of what you read
yeah you skip things
yeah that's cheating that's a thing like
i i train
a lot of you know like notables but
like a lot of doctors you know and uh
you don't want your doctor
your financial advisor your lawyer just
to get the gist of wish
that's not the goal and so for me
there's a woody allen quote says
i took a speed reading class i read war
and peace
it's about russia that's not the goal
right that's not you
you want comprehension you want
retention and um
so for me maybe because i started more
in the memory space
like it then makes sense for me to to
understand
read something not retain it understand
it apply it right
so let's let's look into this there's
two parts of reading there's reading
speed and there's comprehension
and you don't want to have one without
the other right now
reading there are five obstacles to
effective reading
that keep us reading slow or not
understanding as much as we could
and really quickly and people i
encourage everyone if they're not
already taking notes if they can
number one first obstacle is lack of
education all right
no one is born with the ability to read
it was a skill that we learned through
class
right yet when's the last time you took
a class
called reading not like a college elite
class but a class called
reading how old were you
hey i can't even remember learning how
to read in school like my dad taught me
how to read
i i remember people getting taught how
to read in kindergarten at least in
canada
uh and they wouldn't they'd be taught to
memorize words
like they're not even taught properly
they're not taught like q
u makes a qu sound like they're not
taught sounds or c
k is k right it was just like memorize
was
um i remember in kindergarten being
taught like that and it was just
i don't even know how anyone learns how
to read if they're still being taught
like that
no i mean that's a huge advantage being
able to to have that and also just
having that example because i think
reading is to your mind what exercises
to your body when people
see photos regardless of what people
think but like
me and oprah bill gates and elon musk
we bonded over books like leaders are
readers right and i didn't have that
appreciation because i couldn't read
very
well until i was an adult but if
somebody has decades of experience
and they put into a book and you could
sit down and read that book in a few
days
you could download decades into days you
could have a phd you know read a book a
week you have phd in any category
of things that are important to you so
you know i have that love for reading
but reading
you know most people learned in class in
school
and they were like five or six or seven
whatever right
but has a difficulty in demand increase
since we're a child
certainly but how we read is usually how
we first learned it
and we haven't upgraded that training
right and so first
just like getting proper education since
we're
six second obstacle defective reading i
think everyone can relate to most people
lack of focus and this is an obstacle to
effective reading if your mind wanders
you get easily distracted
now it's interesting because it's been
my experience and again
we have students in our speaking class
195 nations and i've trained this
everywhere right harvard caltech you
know it's google
facebook all the intensive places what i
would say
is lack of focus it's interesting it's
been my experience
coaching individuals for three decades
that a lot of lack of focus is because
they're reading too slow
meaning that you have this incredible
brain right we everyone's
you know like everyone talks about the
potential of the brains incredible super
computer device most
you know we know more about space than
we know about yeah but we feed it when
we read
one word uh
and i'm from new york so i can't speak
that slowly but i was to speak that
slowly
in this conversation everyone would just
what fall asleep
they're mine i'd go crazy really quickly
all that and that but those are the same
symptoms people get when they read
they fall asleep how many people use
reading as a sedative there's like a
it's
there's a book by their bed stand that's
been there an embarrassingly long period
of time but they pick it up when they
want to fall asleep
and that's not a good association to
have to reading that puts you to sleep
or or you get easily distracted or your
mind wanders think about other things or
you know or
and that's what happens when i talk
slowly but imagine when you read that
slow that's what your mind is doing and
you wonder why you can't remember
anything
here's the difference though let's say
you're racing
let's say you're driving in your
neighborhood going the regular just too
slow in your neighborhood
you're doing not really focused on
driving you're doing five different
things you're drinking your coffee
taxing thinking about dry cleaning talk
to the kid you're doing five things
where you're going slow
but if you're racing cars you're not
you're not thinking about the dry
cleaning you're not trying to text
you're
checking checking yourself in the mirror
you're focused on the act of driving and
what's in front of you
that's the faster readers it's been our
experience that it's a myth that slow
readers
that faster readers have less
comprehension that if i ask you to read
faster
some people think oh i can't do that i'm
not going to understand as much
but in actuality and we have a lot of
data we find that faster readers
actually have better comprehension
why because they have better focus
because the speed gives them the focus
the focus gives them
the retention the comprehension so
that's number two lack of education and
then finally
other obstacles because you have to
identify what can go wrong and why
things are the way they are third
obstacle is really the big one
sub-vocalization this is actually what
keeps people reading slow
sub-vocalization ever notice when you're
reading you hear that inner voice inside
your head
reading along with you hopefully your
own voice it's not like somebody else's
voice inside your head
mcconaughey's voice now that i've read
his books just everything is that voice
exactly for me it's morgan freeman's
like
that's good too so when i when i when
people read if you hear that inner voice
inside your head
it's called subvocalization the reason
why it's a challenge sub
meaning under like a submarine vocal
meaning speech
it's your inner speech right the reason
why it's an obstacle to effective
reading
is because if you have to say all the
words yeah yeah for sure
read as fast as you could talk that
means your reading speed is limited to
your talking speed not your thinking
speed that's why a lot of people can
listen to this podcast at
1.52x or listen to audio you could
understand that fast but you can't
talk that fast the question becomes the
common sense question is
do i need to pronounce these words in
order to understand them
and they're the because if no because
most of the words are filler words
they're sight words
right just like when you see a stop sign
and you don't say stop
but you understand what it means 95 of
the words we come across
in social media and books maybe whatever
their their sight words they in other
words you've seen before
a hundred thousand times you don't have
to say it in order to understand it
so we find that the fastest readers tend
to subvocalize less
you know and when i still simplify words
that i haven't seen before there's
yeah genetically but that that's a
challenge so mitigate that just like we
don't say punctuation marks you don't
read as a comma
period like these are symbols that you
understand the meaning words are the
same way
and then finally fourth obstacle
regression back skipping is a very bad
habit people do it unconsciously
if you ever find yourself rereading
words or reading whole lines over again
it's just a bad eye habit you know when
we're looking at visual
uh pacers and such when we when actually
in
in research labs i'll have somebody read
something use the same technology
they'll use an advertising to see
where their eyes go during the ad
because they want to put you know the
the product or the brand right in that
view but that same thing when people are
reading they'll use that same technology
and they'll see people's eyes they're
very inefficient they'll go back
and reread things and the back they call
back skipping regression
and it wastes enormous time nor does it
help with your comprehension if
there's a movie that you always wanted
to watch but somebody has a remote
control and every 30 seconds they rewind
it
it's not only going to take longer but
it's not going to help you understand it
it's actually going to disrupt your
understanding because it breaks it up
and then the last one besides back
skipping is limiting beliefs which we
talk a lot about
unlocking limiting beliefs about what's
possible because if you i can show
people how to read faster but if they
believe that they're stupid that they're
too old that they're not smart enough
they're still gonna be stuck in that box
because all behavior is belief driven
right now on the other side of it what's
the what are some answers like some
brain hacks to be able to improve your
focus to remember more what you read to
be able to read faster
a couple quick simple things um and i go
with tips just because the training
would
um you know i would i would need like a
you know a little bit each time each day
in our programs to be able to make the
shift
but a couple things you do get instant
results number one
use a visual pacer use a visual pacer
while you read
um what does that mean it means you're
not you're you're underlining the words
but you're not doing traditional speed
reading will have your finger
or a pen or a highlighter go right down
the page but you're going to miss
everything on the left side of the page
and the right side of the page that's
why you just get the gist
or they'll say fancy finger motions like
make an s form or a z
form there's huge pockets of information
you're going to miss but you get some
keywords so you feel like you got some
scannings gist of what you read i'm not
saying any of that
i'm saying if you use a visual pacer pen
highlighter
mouse on a computer uh your finger as
you underline the words not skipping
anything
test yourself you will read 25 to 50
faster right and don't trust me what i
would recommend everyone do
not take up time here take a book put a
mark in the margin
time yourself for 60 seconds and just
read how you normally read
for 60 seconds then when the timer goes
off put a mark in the margin count the
number of lines
and then pick up where you left off
using a visual pacer you know pen
highlighter
finger just underline the words for full
comprehension how you normally do it
when timer goes off 60 seconds put a lot
mark in the margin count the number of
lines
that second will be the second time will
be 25 50
wow some people will boost it and i'm
curious like you know
like text me i'm going to try this yeah
yeah message me and let me know how much
but most people the across board 25
and now here's why all right because a
lot of people will know what to do but
they don't do what they know
because common sense is not common
practice we know what we should be doing
pretty much you know each day
to have you know to win right but we
don't do it
and that's why the book was a lot spent
a lot of time talking about human
motivation how to overcome
procrastination
the mindset of focus but here's here's
why
first of all children do it you know i
get to work with a lot of children they
will naturally organically use their
finger to help
keep their their focus right until we
tell them not to do it
yeah yeah yeah right and i'm not saying
there's a whole conspiracy trying to
like not keep people educated or
anything else like that
but just just children will naturally
want to do it second of all
you do it like all the adults listening
says you actually do it and you're like
no i don't use my finger when i read but
if i ask you to count the
number of lines you just read a hundred
percent of the people use their finger
and just
one two three four five because they
know having a visual pacer helps them
focus right number three third reason
why
experiment with this number one children
do it and to you do it
number three it's uh your eyes are
attracted to motion
right like if if something just ran
across the screen
screen or your room you wouldn't pay
attention to me you would pay attention
to what moves in your environment
as it's your evolution as a hunter
gatherer
if you're in a bush hunting you know
like
lunch right you're hunting this rabbit
or carrot whatever
people's diet how soon is a rabbit on
your show
you're hunting this rabbit and all of a
sudden the bush next to you
moves you have to look at what moves
because it's your survival number one it
could be lunch
or number two you could be lunch so you
have to look at what's in your
peripheral field
so if your finger is going through the
page like this your attention is being
pulled through
the information as opposed to your
attention being pulled apart so it's
just how we're set up
by movement fourth reason why you do it
is because it's how your neurology is
set up
right and so really simple simplistic
way of thinking about it
have you ever um have you ever tasted a
great tasting piece of
like something right from the farmer's
market like like have you tasted a great
peach yeah yeah you're not tasting the
peach
you're smelling the peach that your
tongue's not capable of tasting what a
peach tastes like
what you're really doing is smelling it
but your sense of smell and taste are so
closely linked in your nervous system
that your mind doesn't perceive the
difference it knows the difference when
you're sick
when you can't breathe out of your nose
what does some foods taste like
it's nothing nothing bland right just as
your sense of smell and taste are
closely linked
so is your sense of sight and your sense
of touch that if you go
to your toddler and you go with your
cart your keys look at my keys look at
my keys
what's the child going to do grab them
right because
they associate and this is there is
actually a link between sense of touch
and sense of sight
in order them to see it they have to
touch it and feel it
right and so that when people read using
their finger
anecdotally i'll hear this all the time
in our in our courses
jim i don't know what's what's happening
here not only being faster but i feel
more in touch with my reading
in touch right kinesthetically the other
reason though it's interesting
oh if somebody loses their sense of
sight how do they read
they use braille right their sense of
touch right that's the link so
these are just some reasons i would
encourage people to give them enough
reasons to practice this and test this
out
you know but a 25 50 lift is huge
that is huge we'll spend four hours a
day
processing information right that means
if you're an employer
half of your team's day spend processing
emails
like business plans whatever you know
and that means half their salary is
being paid just to read
right if you could save two hours a day
if i could just double your reading
speed
save two hours a day i mean forget about
time management you can make time if
you're saving two hours a day
what would you do with those two hours a
day right what
two hours breathe exactly two hours a
day of course that's amazing answer
two hours that's how i
but here's the thing if you're saving
two hours a day over the course of a
year let me like really get to the why
that's how many hours 730 if you save
one hour a day over the course of years
365 hours
how many 40 hour work weeks is that nine
two weeks in two months more than two
months of productivity you get back
to even one hour a day and something
ubiquitous like reading because most of
us still reading like we're a six or
seven year old
right and that's why investing in
something like that will give you
huge amount of returns and then put
those two hours towards you know your
your food your meditation your sleeping
your
your reading your family the things that
we're you know that will make our lives
better
so visual pacer and i would challenge
everyone one other thing when you're
reading if you want greater speed
use your finger while you read now it
doesn't overcome subvocalization
because but where you're getting that
lift is the the time you get to you're
losing when you're back skipping because
you're not going to back skin
yeah consciously when your eyes are
being pulled through the information
and then the subvocalization takes
training right so that's that's where we
lean off
you know get you doing it less but the
other thing if you want greater speed
use your finger while you read
if you want greater comprehension
remember going back to those questions
asking yourself questions even in school
you know when i used to do
like standardized like testing prep and
everything else
study skills which we do courses on
it's like a lot of people will read for
pages and then you know reading
comprehension then be tested like you're
the quiz questions
when everyone should just go to those
questions first and then
read and they're like yeah it's so true
there's an answer
as opposed to reading four pages if
perhaps and then getting down it's like
oh i didn't know that's what they wanted
right but when we're reading that's why
every single chapter in my book starts
with here these are three questions ask
yourself
so prime's the pump like okay there's a
pug dog there's a pot dog there's a pug
dog because if you don't have any
questions
you're not going to get any answers and
the fastest way to read something
is just not to read it at all but a lot
of people pick up a book and they don't
have
an intention or questions they're trying
to solve you know and then
they don't get any answers and they
wonder why and so i would say those two
things
would be a huge lift for everyone
listening in terms of saving time
reading and also getting more out of
your reading by asking better questions
that is so interesting i can remember
when i was literally using my finger
to to keep track of where i was on the
page because i had
problems with skipping or going back uh
and i was definitely taught out of that
firmly
yeah yeah they would do that some people
depending on what school they went to
they got
interesting feedback with a ruler or
something not to do ruler yeah don't use
the ruler i remember
yeah yeah it's this whole thing and it's
just or some people were actually you
know depending on the school they were
punished for using their finger while
they read
and my thing we put um i put on for for
everybody here a
master class it's a one hour masterclass
where you can actually bring a book
and it's free so people go to uh jim
quick.com i hope it's okay
oh yeah yeah yeah gymquick.comreading
and you can actually just bring a book
register for it online and i'll walk you
through i'll time it for you
the one minute the two minutes we'll do
exercises cool
before and after and then you'll just
see the results and then you know and
again when i learn
simple things like this and obviously we
go more advanced with with other
technical reading
you know like and study skills and stuff
but it just happens like wow something
so simple
and yet it wasn't taught you know back
back in school
and so yeah that's
that's crazy i'm i'm really interested
in trying this finger thing
yeah because i haven't had a problem
with the sub vocalization i got rid of
that a while ago
so i don't have an issue i can remember
the switch too when i was like i'm
reading faster than my brain is saying
this and then something switched and i
stopped saying it so
that part's okay but that's remarkable
and then that then you're
you're very fortunate through to nature
or nurture how that you know that
that because a lot of people they learn
reading wrong because
what happened think about school you
passed around the book and you had to
read out loud
and that was terrifying for me because
we were getting these reading circles
and every single time the book got
closer i couldn't read right so i was
just like i think that's where a lot of
fear public my fear of public speaking
yeah no wonder
maybe other people's too it's just like
you're not great at doing something the
first time out and i
when i even get the book i would look at
it and the words meant nothing to me and
i would just pass it on
because i couldn't you know at the time
read i think that's where the fear came
from public speaking
and for a lot of people it's a big fear
i don't know how you are and like
you see are you more extroverted i am so
extroverted i never had an issue with
that at all i
i saw people in my class and they'd
stand up and they'd shake and turn green
and i was like those poor people
self-imposed or environment expectations
or experience but here's the thing
like it's interesting because
sub-vocalization came from your teacher
had to have you read out loud
so they know you're pronouncing the
words correct
but later on the teacher said this read
probably tired of hearing everybody read
quietly to yourself
yeah silently to yourself and that's
where you said oh in order for me to
understand it i have to say it out loud
if not out loud inside my own mind and
we took that voice and put it inside and
it's been there ever since
and it's handcuffed us in terms of our
reading speed now
some things i'll be honest like i read
slowly because i want to get i want to
hear it i want to hear the nuance
of certain literature and so but
here's the thing it's like it's nice a
trained reader to
slow down but they have the ability most
people read about 200 words a minute
that's the average reading speed but
they read everything at 200 words
you know something nice that's just like
walking if you want on a treadmill
everyone just walks at
you know 3.0 or whatever right but it's
nice to have flexibility
and variety to be able to speed up when
you need to just like if you would
like outdoors or you climb out and it's
nice to be trained
right so you can speed up when you want
to get through something fast get to the
the important points and slow down when
you want to be able to save or something
also as well
yeah this is incredibly valuable
information i think i was
fortunate when i was learning how to
read um because i got taught from my dad
my grandpa i i remember him telling me
because i remember saying why do i have
to read in my head i was really little
when i learned how to read
why do i have to read in my head like
why do i have to read silently because
the switch from out loud to silent was
hard and he said
because you can't read as quickly if you
you know say the words out loud
if you don't say the words you can read
faster so i got taught that you know
right off the bat which i think was
really fortunate huge huge advantage and
my my thing for everyone listening you
know
most people um that's a huge a wonderful
gift
to be able to have you know and that's
how that's that's the wonderful way to
be able to share and teach children to
be able to do that
and i would say for anyone who didn't
learn that that's not too late no matter
your age
obviously it'd be great to do it early
on but the next best time do it today
you know moving forward so you get that
benefit just like with people's diet you
know like
yes you did this way for so long but now
you found something else with the new
information we can make a good decision
and our brain is very neuroplastic you
know and so you can make these changes
we change our words
our actions our thoughts our character
our habits you know and then these
things could change us
us back but i would say also to read
schedule the other thing i would say is
schedule it because
the average book has about 64 000 words
on average if you look at amazon and
here's the thing the average person is
about only about 200 words per minute
and we guarantee people will triple
their reading speed with better
comprehension
you know like in all our programs but
let's just say 200 words per minute
here's the thing if you take 64 000
words divided by 200 words a minute
that equals to get through one book 320
minutes
right break it down into seven days in a
week it's 45 minutes a day
you know so it makes it it's doable like
every person reads
two or three books a year but like you
know i think that
to get the high performance reading a
book a week 52 books a year it's a huge
advantage
and how do you get through it just 45
minutes of reading a day and you break
that up into two reading sessions right
and yes it takes time right but what
kind of advantages you get i think
reading is to your mind what exercises
to your body
i spend more time refeeding my mind when
i do my body and i do believe in
you know eating the best foods ever also
as well but 45 minutes a day and if you
can double your eating speed do it in 20
minutes a day right
amazing amazing gift but you need to
schedule it and schedule it around a
time where you're not
really tired because we have these
prototypes right these time types some
people are early birds some people night
owls and so on
schedule a time when your hormones and
your your body's activated physiology is
activated to be able to go through that
activity okay okay so
we're actually at an hour which is when
i end these but
i may have to have you back on because
we didn't even touch on a whole bunch of
things i wanted to touch on like i
wanted to
know about morning routine and we need
to get into memory more
but that we'll have to save for another
time uh where so you mentioned jim quick
slash
reading for a free master class
free speedy reading masterclass through
the process and just bring a book and
i'll time everything i'll ask you the
questions get you how to
take notes and boost your comprehension
that's the gymquick.com process reading
you just says about quick write kwik
it's my real name i need to change it to
do what i do that's nice that's handy
my father's name my grandfather's name
and then i would say you know our our
podcast is really our go to
every episode's uh 15 minutes um it's
quick
oh that's nice yeah i like that how to
change your habits how to be able to
memorize a ted talk
i do a lot of you know training for
actors teach them how to memorize
scripts and so
how to study better every episode it's
only 15 minutes so people binge listen
to that on itunes or
spotify or whatever and then the book is
actually at limitlessbook.com
we're very fortunate the book we were
going to delay it because of what was
going on in the world but i was like
this book is more than a book on speed
reading remember names learning
languages
it's about managing your mind in time of
crisis
or regaining your productivity or float
or force to work from home
or supporting your kids if you're in and
out of school or
you know how to learn a new subject or
skill rapidly if you've lost your job
and so um that book is that's at
limitlessbook.com and when people go
there
there's a free 10 day gift and we donate
100 of the proceeds to charity
we donated every cent to this book to
alzheimer's research for women
as women what likely the experience of
alzheimer's than men
and yet all the most the research is
done on male brains most of treatments
are done on male brains
and um i lost my grandmother to
alzheimer's when i was going through my
learning challenges
at the age of you know five six seven my
my parents were
working because my grandmother took care
of me and she uh
when i ended up taking care of her at
ages six and seven bringing her food
because she had alzheimer's since she
passed the
alzheimer's i do that in her memory and
we donate the other portions
to build schools for children around the
world who have no access to education so
we built
we just didn't know 50 000 this month's
two pencils of promise
we built schools healthcare that keeps
kids from going to school when they're
sick
clean water because a lot of the girls
are going getting water for hours and
days so they don't go to school
we build schools ever from ghana
guatemala kenya all around the world
and so it's real passion project you
know i grew up with learning challenges
so i'm passionate about education
i grew up with brain challenges so man i
lost my grandmother alzheimer's i'm very
passionate about brain health
so um you know i believe the foreign
meals you learn so you can earn so you
can return
right and then be able to give back and
so we
our mission is to build better brighter
brains you know no brain left behind
this is the mission so i appreciate this
conversation everyone is listening
so limitless all my other author guests
just look
really bad now no no no no i'm not
saying that at all i'm just saying that
i know i know but i would challenge can
i give everyone a little one one
challenge
i would challenge everyone to screenshot
this episode
and here's the thing when you hear
something you learn it once
but when you share it and teach it you
learn it twice and i would challenge
every single
person that not to let just knowledge
have it be potential power let it be
real power so screenshot this episode
a tag attack us both in it
you know on wherever you are on social
media and just share
one thing you're going to do for your
better brain just one thing you're going
to do for your better brain
or the other thing is i'd love to know
what your dominant question is
or mine was how to become how do i
become invisible how do i shrink down
and then it became how do i make things
better what do you think your dominant
question is
that you ask all the time and then post
it i'll actually repost some of my
favorites
yeah i'll repost too that's fine and
i'll actually actually send a copy of
this book
a signed copy of this book to one person
just as a fun way of just
i think learning passively the human
brain does not learn
through consumption the human brain
learns better through creation
and i'm saying learning is like life is
not a spectator sport
so be active yeah one little thing like
take a snapshot of this
or take a picture of your notes you know
tag us both in it
i'll repost a couple also but then when
you share with your fans your followers
your friends your family they see it
maybe that inspires them to be able to
build their better brain
that was so cool thank you very much for
coming on
i appreciate it and um and we'll do it
again sometime
yes yeah there's i definitely want to
get more into the memory i want to
know what you do for nutrition and i
want to know about the morning routine
so we'll save that for another
episode i can't wait
[Music]
you